what are you enjoying most about this
journey
donuts so far
as rihanna prepares for motherhood her
best project yet a source tells e.t that
she and boyfriend rapper asap rocky will
be quote very hands-on parents i'm just
excited for what i don't know yet you
know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited the source says
quote while rihanna and asap rocky may
be one of the most successful celeb
couples when it comes down to their
private life they're actually pretty
humble i know thank you so much it's no
question that their baby can have
anything in the world but the source
adds quote more than anything this baby
will be spoiled with love and attention
i'm looking forward to it also with ties
to new york los angeles and barbados the
source says this baby is going to be
well traveled while la will be the home
base for their family they'll likely
spend time in the hamptons this summer
in rihanna's home country of barbados
will be one of their first trips with
the baby it's all an exciting journey so
far i'm just taking it as it comes as
far as seeing riri out and about after
she gives birth the source shares that
in the early days with the baby we can
expect the beauty mogul to keep a low
profile
fashion is one of my favorite things now
it would be wrong to expect anything
other than rihanna to continue to be a
fashion killer even through her
pregnancy the 33 year old has been
slaying her maternity looks which is
something she opened up to e.t about
recently at an immersive beauty event
honoring her fenty beauty and fenty skin
lines you know redefining what it means
to even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend
of course with the baby on the way fans
are eager to know if we can expect new
music anytime soon here's what rihanna
tells
well let's talk about this other baby
that we all want to know about
when is this maybe do you think this
stage in your life is going to inspire
new music
oh gosh
you can't ever you know this one my fans
love you you know because you asked all
the good questions
uh well
yes you're still gonna get music from me
maybe a lullaby i can see you and asap
dropping demos in the studio
oh my goodness not a lullaby my fans
would kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby letting us sleep with this
music we are grown
[Music]